hi it's Michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD and cosmetic chemist
I recently ranked the top products
mentioned in the skincare addiction
subreddit where I used to be
a moderator from 2014 to 2019
a lot of people asked me to rank the top
products from the Asian beauty subreddit
too and I thought this would be interesting
because the list is very different in vibe
Asian beauty is on reddit which is
very text-based so there is still a
big focus on what works I think no one
likes to buy products that don't work
the products are still quite budget friendly
from a 2017 survey eighty percent of the Asian
beauty subredditors said affordability
influenced their purchasing but about
two-thirds said they also wanted
to experiment with new and trendy
products so the products this time
are I think a bit more interesting
again the actual rankings part is going to
be pretty subjective because I don't think
it is possible to rank anything without
some subjectivity but as always I will
explain my ranks so you can compare
that against your own needs and wants
my scale goes from holy grail which
is products I love to death solid
choice which is stuff I would happily
recommend to my friends and most people
really and then all the way down to
not for anyone maybe for my enemies
and there's also a space for products I haven't
tried myself for long enough to have an opinion on
based on my own experiences trying to
predict how products are going to go on
my skin and what I've learned over the
years looking into the science of skin
care and in my cosmetic chemistry training
you can't really make accurate predictions
based on just an ingredients list and it is
pretty misleading when people try to do that
as usual these are my opinions on the products
your skin might not like what my skin likes
as an indication I have oily skin that gets
dehydrated easily and likes to clog up it
likes to produce a lot of pigment and I live
in sydney which is pretty humid but as usual
definitely don't stop using a product
you love just because I didn't like it
this time we are going to go
from number 20 for extra suspense
number 20 is the canmake mermaid skin
gel sunscreen this is one of only two
sunscreens in the top 20 which I thought
was interesting because sunscreens are
one of the most popular categories of
Asian skincare products but there are
a lot of really popular ones so
maybe that diluted the mentions
Looria this website just counts the
number of mentions it doesn't
distinguish between good or bad
this is a Japanese sunscreen and Asian beauty does
generally only cover Japanese and Korean products
the entire top 20 is just from those two countries
there are obviously a lot more countries in
Asia and some of them have a lot more
people like india indonesia and china
but maybe because they have so many people their
beauty brands don't really tend
to focus on exporting overseas
Japan and Korea tend to do a lot of soft
diplomacy where they try to export their
culture overseas and I think that's
why in a subreddit like Asian beauty
which largely has western redditors you
see more of these countries' products
this has spf 50+and pa++++ which is the
highest rating you can get in Japan it's
a combination sunscreen with a mix of old and
new chemical filters as well as physical filters
this used to have a really fantastic
formula it was lightweight it had
barely any white cast and it was in my top
sunscreen recommendations for a long time
it's been through a bunch of changes so I
think first there was new packaging with
the old formula and then they changed the
insides as well and it seems like the new
version does have white cast but the old
version is still stocked in some places
Japanese sunscreens tend to reformulate
and not change their packaging and most
of the info on Japanese sunscreens and skincare
is in Japanese which makes it a bit
harder to work out what is going on
so I think the reason this
is in the top mentions is
because people are confused and asking questions
if this was the old version it would go straight
up to the holy grails but for the
new version it's either meh or bad
compared to western sunscreens it is
still pretty good but the confusion
around this does annoy me a lot
because people did buy this off
my recommendation and some of you
got a completely different product
I always feel really bad when people
end up with bad purchases because of
me that is why it takes me so darn long
to come out with review videos I spend
weeks testing the product
and days prepping the video
I'm going to put it into bad because there are
so many other sunscreens that
are just less stressful to buy
number 19 is the round lab dokdo cleanser
round lab is quite a popular brand in Korea their
birch juice sunscreen is really
nice I've reviewed that before
this isn't the packaging I have my one has a
little seal on the tube and it has a little
face and it brings me a lot of joy which
automatically gives it bonus points for me
this is a really nice cleanser that gives
lots of dense foam but it still has a low
pH cleansers that have like dense luxurious foam
are really popular in Asia and honestly everywhere
because lots of us like foam when we cleanse
and it makes us feel like it is more cleaning
but to get this texture of foam a lot of brands
will use soap surfactants that only work at high
pH and this can be an issue if your skin is
acne prone or dehydration prone which mine is
I've been disappointed so many times by
Asian cleansers that have really lovely
foam and then after I use them for
a few weeks my skin ends up dry and
irritated and then I test it and check the
ingredients and it's got soap surfactants
this one uses isethionate and taurate
which are surfactants that tend to
give this sort of foam texture but they
don't need to be formulated at high pH
having a mix of lots of different
surfactants makes mixed micelles
which are gentler on skin I've talked
about it in my video on cleansing myths
foam on its own doesn't really tell you much about
whether a product is going
to strip your skin or not
I don't know if I would call these surfactants
natural they are according to a lot of natural
certification bodies but that's because
their rules are kind of really arbitrary
there's just a list of chemical
reactions that count as natural
for some reason and others count as synthetic
I think these certification bodies just use
this as a loophole because if their brands
stuck to truly natural ingredients
they would have like nothing left
these sorts of pseudoscience marketing concepts
like clean and the ewg and natural are
getting more and more popular in Korea
there is this assumption that Korean
skincare is really innovative and
science based but just like anywhere else
people still fall for cognitive biases
this cleanser also has a whole bunch
of really nice hydrating ingredients
like glycerin hyaluronic acid allantoin panthenol
ceramides and this compensates for the
stripping that comes from cleansing
I really like this cleanser it's really
gentle and that seal really does bump it
up so I'm going to put it into holy grail and
I think this will work for most people's skin
number 18 we have the cosrx bha blackhead power
liquid like a lot of other Korean bha products
this uses betaine salicylate because of
the regulations around salicylic acid
but it does just split up into
salicylic acid and betaine once
there's water around and the amount
of salicylic acid versus salicylate
ions just depends on the pH that the
product gets adjusted to at the end
this also has willow bark water which is a natural
source of salicin that gets converted
into salicylic acid if you eat it it's
a traditional remedy for headaches but
not really if you put it on your skin
this also has niacinamide which is a really trendy
ingredient that started off getting
popular in Asian skincare products
I think the reason this is so
popular is that it was one of
the few salicylic acid products from
an Asian brand for a really long time
it might also be this high
because cosrx is probably the
most popular Korean beauty brand for US consumers
I personally didn't see much of a difference when
I used this probably because I use so
much paula's choice two percent bha
in general I would recommend getting
chemical exfoliants from western
brands because it is one of the categories
that is really lacking in Asian skin care
I think this could be an option if you
find western products a bit too harsh so
I'm probably going to put this in meh but let me
know if you've have really good results from this
number 17 is the kose softymo speedy cleansing oil
cleansing oils is one of the options you have
for the first step of a double cleansing
routine which is really popular in Asia
this is where you start off with an
oil-based cleanser like a cleansing
oil or a balm and then you follow up with
a water-based cleanser like a foaming gel
double cleansing is a pretty gentle and
effective way to get rid of waterproof
makeup and sunscreen and this
cleansing oil I really enjoy
it's really good value it's really effective and
it's also fragrance free but it smells neutral so
it is really suitable for a wide range of people
without having that sort of fragrance free smell
I found that this removes eyeliner well
I don't get any eye sting or blurriness
it has a nice pump which dispenses
an amount that you actually want
there are some really bad pumps out there
my personal gripe with cleansing oils
is just that getting them from my hand
onto my face without anything dripping
on the floor is a bit more difficult
my partner gets really annoyed about this and
oils require a bit more effort to clean up than
water-based products so I just prefer
something more solid and more portable
but yeah there aren't really
no other downsides to this it
is just a solid recommendation I'm
going to put this up into holy grail
on to number 16 and I have changed
the lighting background because it is
really hot here and the pink I don't know
maybe it made me feel like I was in hell
I also have an ice pack in my lap because yeah
australia
this is the kikumasamune hopefully
that is somewhere near the correct
pronunciation high moist lotion and it
is the only body product on this list
it's an Asian lotion which is a
product that has a very liquidy
toner consistency sort of like the
runniness of milk it is really liquid
it's not what you would expect
if you come from like a western
skincare background and you think lotions
are thicker creamier moisturizer products
it has a lot of really interesting ingredients
there's a big focus on pigment targeting and
brightening ingredients like sake extract
which has kojic acid this product is actually
made by a sake company there's arbutin
glycyrrhizate which is a licorice extract
there's also hydrating ingredients
like ceramides and glycerin
the smell of this is a little bit weird
to me it starts smelling like fresh
apple cider and then it very quickly
kind of turns into old apple cider
kind of like if you spilt some apple cider
on a pub table and left it for half an hour
I found that the smell went
away pretty quickly after
about 10 seconds but I can imagine
that it might bother some people
it's super hydrating it can also
get a bit onto the sticky side
as you might expect having a pump with what is
basically water in it is a bit tricky I've seen
some people decant this into a bottle or spray
which should be pretty safe given the ingredients
I've only used it in the pump but I kind of cup
my hand around it to try to
you know catch all the splash
I mostly use this on my body for hydration
and maybe to help tackle some dark marks
it is a lot easier to rub in than
like a western lotion but it might
not be quite enough if you live somewhere very dry
I think if this works on your face it would be
incredible value but some people
do say it breaks them out a bit
and that could potentially be purging it
might go away after your skin's adjusted
I'm going to put this into solid choice
I think it can be a bit risky with the
fragrance but I think if you don't mind
the fragrance and it works for your face
then it could get bumped up to holy grail
number 15 is a repeat that we'll get to later
but number 14 is the cosrx low pH cleanser
low pH cleansers are a selling point
in Korean skincare because a lot of
cleansers were really high pH for a
long time and a lot of them still are
this product has been around
for a while and despite the
low pH which is around 5.3 a lot of people
including me still find this really drying
it might be because there aren't
that many surfactants in this
so you're not getting that
mixed micelle gentle effect
there's also no real hardcore humectants or
moisturizers in the formula to try
to replace what gets washed away
there are some natural extracts but
I think these are mostly way too
water soluble to stay around
on your skin after cleansing
I think it is popular because
it's cosrx it's really easy
to get in the US and it is really budget friendly
but I think it is worth it to pay a bit more to
get a less drying cleanser if your
skin does get tight after cleansing
I have oily skin and getting a gentle cleanser has
made a really big difference to how manageable the
oil is plus I think it kind of balances out
because then you save on hydrating products
so I'm going to put this in there
I would recommend the round lab cleanser over this
other inexpensive options are the heimish
green foam and the hada labo hyaluronic foam
number 13 is the biore uv aqua rich watery essence
this is another Japanese sunscreen it has spf
50+ and pa++++ as well as some water resistance
this was many people's first Asian
sunscreen kind of like their gateway
sunscreen and it shows up a lot in
my top sunscreen recommendations
it has a lot of the features that Asian sunscreens
are really known for it's really lightweight
and it feels refreshing to apply which is a
really stark contrast from western sunscreens
this sits really nicely under
makeup and it contains some of
those newer filters that give better uva
protection as well as that light texture
this does contain alcohol but
it's not a big problem for most
people because it also has moisturizing
ingredients that counteract that effect
this has a mild floral scent and
it's easily available and not
very expensive although you do need to
watch out for fakes on amazon and ebay
overall this is great but I do feel a
little bit hesitant to put it into the holy
grails because it does get reformulated
quite frequently about every two years
the newest 2023 version has just come
out which I haven't quite tried yet
but all of the formulations I've
tried which is about three or four
of them have been great so I think it is
pretty safe to chuck it into holy grails
number 12 is the etude house soon jung emulsion
I haven't tried this but I do want to
try it there is another product from
this range coming up so this
is going into the no opinion
number 11 is the isntree green tea fresh toner
this is a toner that's based
on green tea and some other
plant extracts these all have antioxidant benefits
I tried this for about a week which isn't
really long enough to give it a thorough
review but I have had toners do a lot
more for my skin in that amount of time
this is very lightly hydrating and there are
reviews from people who have said that it
helps reduce their oil over time in general
I've personally found that green tea is a
pretty underwhelming ingredient on my skin and
I think I'm just not that much of a toner person
I am a bit of a minimalist with
my routine so toners that don't
give that much of a hydrating effect are
pretty much one of the first products to
go it is really affordable though
so I'm gonna put it in meh for now
I am open to being convinced let me know in the
comments how you found this if you've tried it
number 10 is the I'm from rice
toner and that is not the correct
product image the i'm from range has
a bunch of star ingredients that are
trending in Asian skin care and
this one is from the rice range
it also has niacinamide and adenosine
which is a combo I've seen in a lot
of Korean skincare products and the
reason for this I think is because
it allows them to be marketed as
anti-aging functional cosmetics
this is really nice and light I
did find that it had a little bit
of a brightening effect on me but I
preferred the cream from this range
the i'm from rice cream has this really lovely
texture that works really nicely under makeup
it is under my makeup right now and again I
think I'm just not that much of a toner person
it is on the pricier end for a toner
and some people do have issues with rice
extract so so I'm going to put this
in meh or solid choice I don't know
I'm gonna put it in solid choice if it was
cheaper it would definitely be in solid choice
number nine is the etude house soon
jung 2x barrier intensive cream
this line is formulated with panthenol and
madecassoside which is from centella extract
it's the same combination of ingredients that you
see in the la roche posay cicaplast baume b5 which
is a cult product one of my favorite products for
soothing and dealing with irritated unhappy skin
people seem to have mixed experiences
with this product some people love
it and swear by it and some it
just didn't really work well for
for me I found that it didn't work
as well as cicaplast for things like
tretinoin peeling and irritation it
feels like it kind of just sits on
top of my skin and it doesn't really go
down and hydrate as well as I would like
it also has this really interesting twist lock
dispenser you flip it open and then you have to
twist the cap to let the product come out
of what looks like a mercedes-benz symbol
it's really cool and different but
at the same time it makes it really
difficult to to dispense a little bit and
the tube itself is quite small so I went
through this really quickly much faster
than I did with a cicaplast baume tube
some people with dry skin have complained
that it wasn't as moisturizing as they
hoped but it does seem to work really well for
people who have really easily irritated skin
I think one of the other products
in the line might work better for
my skin so maybe the emulsion or
they have a hydro barrier cream
and I think those ones would deliver
more hydration which is what I am after
they also have a balm product that seems to
be a lot heavier but it's more
like a targeted spot treatment
I am so sorry to the people who
love it but I'm going to put it
to meh for people in general because I
think there are moisturizers with much
higher satisfaction rates but if you
think this might work for you I would
definitely recommend trying out a sample
because you might be one of the lucky ones
if this does work for you let me know in the
comments what your skin type your climate what
other moisturizers you like are and maybe we
can narrow down who this works really well for
number 8 is that I'm from mugwort essence
I haven't tried this for long enough to
have a real opinion it is 100% mugwort
extract which is artemisia princeps
mugwort is a herb that's getting more
popular in Korean skincare it's kind of
like the new centella it seems to
be good for redness and breakouts
this product is a bit on the pricey side but
it has really good reviews
from people who like mugwort
number seven is the hada labo premium lotion
this is a classic super hydrating hyaluronic
acid toner or essence again that word lotion
in Asian skincare isn't really what we think
of as a lotion in western skincare but this is
starting to change because I think Asian brands
are starting to realize there is this confusion
this has lots of different forms of hyaluronic
acid and I find that in general products that
have lots of different sizes of HA tend
to give more well-rounded hydration at
different depths of your upper layer of skin
it kind of gives longer lasting hydration
so some of the smaller bits can go
into your skin and hydrate deeper
some of the bigger bits can sit more on
top and catch water as it tries to leave
this product has been a staple for a
really long time in reddit skincare
communities from when I first started really
getting into reddit skincare in like 2013
it's really inexpensive it comes in a large bottle
one time I tried to buy a bottle during
a stopover in malaysia but it exceeded my
liquid limit and that was like the one time
terrorists have really ruined my way of life
I'm going to put this into solid choice and
I think this is again my bias against toners
that don't do much except for hydrate it is
really hydrating but these days there are tons
of toners that hydrate as well as doing other
things too so yeah that's going to sit there
and number six is the cosrx
propolis toner speaking of
toners that hydrate and do other things
this is one of them propolis is
really popular in Korean skincare
it's basically like the bee glue that
they use to stick their hives together
it has a lot of antioxidant
and anti-inflammatory effects
and it's been investigated for wound healing
my impression of propolis for a long time
was that it was mostly targeted at acne
prone skin so I didn't try it for ages
I've been converted though propolis
has been really nice for smoothing
out my skin without any sort of irritation
I have pollen allergies so I've been
a bit hesitant about bee products
but all the ones I've tried from Asian
skincare brands have been really soothing
this toner is really light a lot lighter
than other propolis products like the
skinfood enrich essence and yeah you can
see all of the hydrating and soothing
ingredients there there's honey glycerin
betaine hyaluronic acid and panthenol
you do need to use a bit more product than like
the skinfood enrich essence but
this is really budget friendly
I think this might actually may be holy grail
solid choice or holy grail
oh
I'm gonna put it into solid choice because I
haven't really tried it for long enough but I
think there's a good chance once I try it for
longer it's going to jump up into holy grail
number five is the laneige cream skin refiner
this is a really lovely moisturizer
it's kind of like they say a cream
that's been turned into a liquid
it's a relatively unique product
it's one of my friend hannah english's
favorite products for irritated skin
she has dry skin it works well for me too
in winter and I have relatively oily skin
and it also comes as a convenient mist so you can
just spray it over your makeup for example it has
the same ingredients list but I'm not sure if
it is maybe a slightly watered down version
it's a relatively short ingredients list for an
emulsion which has a lot of oil as well
as water-based ingredients there's no
fragrance there's no niacinamide which
makes this a bit of a rarity I think
but if you do like niacinamide and fragrance there
is a copycat product from heimish which has those
I'm going to put this into solid choice
especially if you have dry skin or if
you want what's pretty much a moisturiser
that you can spray on your face over makeup
number four is the pyunkang yul essence toner
I actually reviewed this recently it was
included in gothamista's favorite products
a few years back it's a really inexpensive
toner but it's not really a one step toner
it's not really hydrating it is
based on plant extracts and I
think this could be a nice really
lightly hydrating toner in summer
this is hovering between solid choice and meh
for me I think it is probably a solid choice
if you like doing lots of layers of toner a
lot of people love this for the seven skins
method it's really lightweight and it is really
inexpensive despite it looking pretty premium
whoever designed this ranking system needed to
have more granularity in it they
really didn't think this through
number three is the illiyoon
ceramide ato concentrate cream
okay I need to do some complaining
this has two of my product icks
first off it says 7 free
right on the front of the tube
so if you've been here for long enough if
you've watched enough of my content you probably
know how much I hate free from clean beauty
marketing because it's based on pseudoscience
you probably want me to just skip over this and
move on but here is why I keep mentioning it
brands putting it on the front of
their packaging is a calculated move
they figured that this will bring
in more customers than it puts off
so if people like me aren't vocal
about the fact that it is off-putting
then more brands will keep doing it
because they don't see the downside
but the problem is that less
educated consumers will come
across brands doing this and assume that
there is some sort of legitimate benefit
the presence of this label acts as consumer
education it isn't like a neutral harmless thing
customers will ask brands who don't have this
label if they're also seven free and more and
more brands will be pressured into putting this
on their labels without any sort of pushback
so I feel a responsibility to kind
of be part of the pushback and try
to reduce this seemingly benign but
actually quite insidious misinformation
the other ick is this has like little
bursting beads in it they're like these
white granules inside the product they kind
of give this illusion of the product having
concentrated ingredients like these are
the actives and you can actually see them
in a few products these beads are there to
keep ingredients stable but I'm always worried
that they won't mash up properly and i'll
just be walking around with dots on my face
for this product they do seem to
blend in reasonably easily and I
use them mostly at night so it is mostly okay
this product was reformulated at the
end of 2021 and it might be highly
mentioned because of that again
lots of people are discussing it
there's a lot of mixed reviews
on whether the old version or
the new version are better or
if there's even any difference
the beads seem to be larger in the old version and
the old version also seems to
be a bit lumpier and less thick
to me the moisturizing properties of this are
quite similar to the etude house soon jung barrier
cream but there's no panthenol or madecassoside
so it's not really as targeted for barrier repair
I found that this didn't really do enough
to hydrate my skin there's not much of
an occlusive or humectant effect even though
glycerin is near the top of the ingredient list
I found that I needed to really
hydrate my skin underneath and
that could make sense because most Asian
skincare routines would have that step
but it is a pretty bland product
and it sinks into skin nicely so
it could be good if your skin is really irritated
I think it's quite interesting that
this cream and the soon jung cream
both seem to lack occlusiveness and
I'm wondering if it might be because
petrolatum and mineral oil aren't
really that common in Korean products
I've been seeing these a lot more in free
from lists than in the actual ingredient
list and a lot of Korean products
seem to pride themselves on not
using them they really go on about how
they only have green grade ewg products
but petrolatum and mineral oil are just
really really good occlusives it is
relatively difficult to make a long lasting
overnight moisturizer without using them
this is in a giant pack though
and it is reasonably cheap so
I'm gonna put this into I think solid choice
although I am tempted to dock marks for that
7 free because I am really annoyed at that
I'm gonna be petty today
number two is the cosrx snail mucin essence
this was the product that was also
at number 15 and it looks like if
looria combined all those mentions
this would end up as number one
this is the one product that was on both the
skincare addiction and the Asian beauty top 20
it was number 10 on that one the next Asian
skincare product in the sea list is at number 27
I've talked about this product a lot recently
there are lots of reasons why
I think it is mentioned so much
first off snail slime is exotic and
it plays into this whole idea of like
mystical Asian skincare secrets so it is
just a really kind of gimmicky product
although it actually works really
well for a lot of people it packs
this really huge hydrating punch which is
really good for a glowy glass skin look
it also has a really fun sort of stringy texture
it looks good in videos and it trended on tiktok
plus again cosrx is really
budget friendly and easy to find
I really love this product it is super
hydrating and even though it does seem
a bit gimmicky it has been a staple in a lot
of people's skincare routines for a long time
it does break some people
out with closed comedones
but otherwise it is really good I'm
going to put this up in holy grails
I think it has stood the test of time it's just a
product that seems to work really
well for a lot of people's skin
finally we have product
number one which is drum roll
the melano cc essence I'm really
happy with this at number one
it was also the one that was
on number 27 in the sca list
this is a vitamin c product with ascorbic acid
and the main thing that is super cool
about this is actually the packaging
the packaging is this really
clever airtight dispenser that
limits oxidation really effectively like
oxygen just cannot get into this thing
you actually have to squeeze this really
hard for just like one drop to come out I
have a tube that I opened around probably
january 2021 and now more than two years
later there is dried up brown stuff on
like the thread of the cap but if you
squeeze it the stuff that comes out is still
completely colorless it is just mind-blowing
this is marketed as an anti-acne product
in Japan it has a bunch of ingredients
like potassium glycyrrhizate
which is the active ingredient
in licorice it's anti-inflammatory as well as
isopropylmethylphenol which is antibacterial
as well as that cool packaging keeping
it stable for ages it has a delivery
system that helps the ingredients
straight deeper it's based on glycol
it has a really different texture from a lot of
vitamin c products though it's got this sort of
really thick draggy oil like texture but it does
sink in pretty quick it feels a lot like an oil
I found this really non-irritating
it has a really light scent and on
my skin it worked really well to even
out skin tone from shallow pigment
for me that's mostly when I have
post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation
after a pimple heals and that is
the main reason I use vitamin c
so I think this is just a really cool and
unique product it is fantastic for people
who don't use vitamin c that much and you
need something that will last like a decade
and yes I am planning to keep this
tube for as long as possible so ask
me in I don't know 2031 what this looks like
so that is going into the holy grails
so overall I think these products are
a lot more diverse than the ones we
saw from skincare addiction that had
lots of fragrance free products lots
of simple cleansers and moisturizers and
a handful of single ingredient products
this set of products have a lot more
different active ingredients and there
are a bit more controversial products
that have mixed opinions on them and
I think that's because Asian beauty
tends to have a bit more discussion
there's more I guess advanced skincare
users there people want to explore stuff
so with skincare addiction we had a
lot more solid choice products because
everything was just pretty inoffensive
but these ones I think are a lot more
interesting there's a lot more in the meh
tier for reasons that are quite unique to me
overall here there are 13 products
from Korea and six from Japan and
the Japanese products are all
sort of older legacy products
that started being popular a long time ago
the newest one is probably from like 2015
at the moment Korean products are
a lot more popular and there are a
lot of new ones here although there are
still lots of sort of legacy products
I think that's because Korean products
just tend to be cheaper on the whole and
there is also a lot of support
from the Korean government for
beauty brands to export their products
again that is that soft diplomacy thing
the Korean government is actually sponsoring
beauty stores to export products
which is kind of mind-blowing
I cannot imagine the australian
government doing that
so it's a lot easier for western
redditors to buy Korean products
plus there is a lot more information in
English compared to for Japanese products
let me know what you thought of
these products what you thought
of my rankings please don't be
too mad at me these are subjective
let me know if there's a way of using some of
these products that I just don't know
about that might change my rankings
you can also check out my rankings of
the skincare addiction products and I
have some Korean skincare reviews
that I've done recently as well
I hope you enjoyed this chatty video and
I am going to run off and desweat now